tai chi chi le sosie raté regardez alors
c'est qui alors on a parlé de partout la
barrière c'est qui le saisit gratter de
kent et villages et angelina jolie
angela jolie brabo julie way et les
phobies ratés dans le déni la jolie way
toutankhamon away sur la sur la quête de
cet os 6 à l âme noire
ouais ouais c'est pas mal l opel est pas
mal quand même
ouais mais bon et l'autre non ça n'est
pas tant les morts oui fait savoir quand
le chercheur diamanté miroir elle a fait
cadeau 3ème ciblerie sinon ouais quand
même
mais y'a pas bien quel jackson quand
même bien car aujourd'hui on compte y
aller ou pas non mais au calme dans le
camp même ton truc
bah oui mais c'est la sosie de voix la
sienne solide on est une jolie et il
paraît qu'elle a pas fait de chirurgie
esthétique un an